Priyanka Gandhi her name alone draws
thousands onto the streets fans jostle
for a glimpse of political royalty
descendant of three Indian Prime
Minister's this election she's
campaigning for her brother and Congress
hoping to topple Narendra Modi from
power among the crowd farmers chant for
change when their vote you win the
election hundreds of miles south in the
fields of Maharashtra Lucia scrapes up
the bone-dry remains of her cotton crop
a farmer's life is very difficult she
tells me a mother of two she now has to
work twice as hard her husband killed
himself depressed by years of debt
drought and failing crops more than
12,000 Indian farmers killed themselves
in the year anisha's village four other
families share her pain Sunita's grief
is raw her husband poisoned himself last
year her hope for her children is gone
going out of a Hyderabad hello my dear
me forever lovely Angkor Wat a raga you
could get a
no decent job got a they don't have them
go this election Modi's vowing to help
farmers with pensions and huge rural
investment Congress to with new budgets
and money for the poorest but some here
are angry is my government boo boo [ __ ]
I remember one case and oh god ah
partial nudity or quick government
policy name indeedy ki-sun Maggio
America Abner so said my goal along with
Vijay has seen too many friends died and
watched his own crops struggle but he's
not ready to give up on the pier
darling I beat all what is her carrying
the election could be shaped in these
fields but if Congress is relying on
farmers for victory they could have a
fight on their hands
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Maharashtra
India